[Música]
[Aplausos]
durante o projeto
o meu crescimento das vendas a unidade
província é também pelo pelo evento e
pensar um pouquinho fora de casa e fora
da caixa
o que é relevante é nessa nossa cidade e
meio depois exemplo alguns dos colegas
que me antecederam dizer que é a
primeira vez que estou lá cá vi muitas
vezes ao cinema quando estava exilado
é impossível pelo galinheiro que era o
último o último andar mas também é a
primeira vez na minha vida que estou a
falar pra minha família está aqui na
linha da frente e pra mim antiga
professora marina havia 40 anos
posto isto é minha intenção é um pouco
fazer um arco daquilo que é o exército
na atualidade messi entrar máxima tudo é
naquilo que são os caminhos da paz e
todas as missões que o exército
português tem cumprido e nesse sentido
vou focalizar e vou terminar minha é a
minha intervenção naquilo que eu
considero que é mais governo e que as
pessoas têm mais africana
é isso meu objetivo e para tal presente
nos dá como como o primeiro parto título
da minha apresentação
é aquilo que é visando quanto o exército
e que é prudente então talvez a mulher
com um currículo dele é esse o objetivo
do comandante do exército e essa
intenção
aqui não salvaguarda uma declaração em
que ele tem que fazer como subcomandante
da brigada de reacção rápida é tenho
como uma das minhas no inverno sendo
tratada por sánchez que é um número que
é primeiramente unidade consegue criar
uma simbiose perfeita e uma integração
perfeita com a cidade e é não não vejo
aqui expressão qualquer espécie
eu como sou militar também de processos
judiciais conheço esse percurso é e sei
o que é que entre como a casa gasta
aqui é o paradigma essa cidade amiga
paradigma prefeito daquilo que é esta
simbiose entre a sociedade civil e elita
ser aguentar essa situação entre as
tinha que fazer depois dizer que é em
termos da missão do exército e faz parte
da minha apresentação de ver isto
naquilo que é intervenção interna e
entre vençam extrema naquilo que diz
respeito à intervenção interna
nós temos como missões participar na
defesa militar da república é a
cooperação com as forças de segurança em
computação civil coordenar nessa
discussão das cidades básicas e ea
qualidade das funções aqui que nós
chamamos o apoio ao desenvolvimento e
bem estar das populações
ou ainda mais a proteção e salvaguarda
das pessoas e mexe é isso que fazemos
entre o médio está o foi a sustentação
das forças que projetamos para ele as
operações no exterior e por último a
participação em missões internacionais
participaram em missões no exterior do
território nacional
na salvaguarda da vida e dos interesses
portugueses naquilo que nós chamamos de
força de reação imediata que tem como
missão evacuar os portugueses que em
qualquer sítio possível uma mão forte e
segura pode trazer bom isso nosso
objetivo é essa missão é também uma das
missões importantes a minha empregada
que comanda basicamente como empresta
dessa força a essa meta
depois finalmente executar ações
portanto tem que montar trouxe aqui
além dos aspectos culturais todos seus
aspectos aqui porque considera relevante
e por que está presente principalmente
todas as áreas da cidade e nas áreas
científicas também o que vemos aqui são
alguns dos projetos que nós temos com as
entidades universidades mais
credenciadas no país por exemplo aquilo
que está escrito deus lhes são
protocolos que nós temos com necessidade
do porto
e é com isso trabalhamos fortemente para
evitar que haja acontecimentos não faz
tanto no que diz respeito à proporção de
nosso nossas tropas especiais dos
comandos dos partidos das operações
policiais têm uma ligação fortíssima em
um controlo muito apertado
exatamente com a universidade do porto e
são monitorizados a todo o tempo e cada
vez mais no sentido de evitar que haja
algum acontecimento é meu diz não faz
tudo pra isso com tantos outros
trabalhamos efetivamente na área da
realidade virtual e aumentada
estamos em todos os patamares daquilo
que é a inovação daquilo que é o de
investigação e desenvolvimento através
de um centro de investigação daquele
militar designado como esse na minha mão
que quem tem essa responsabilidade nisso
e esses são alguns dos temas do combate
do seu lado que nós temos é é fazer um
juramento cip e com isso contamos com
todas as empresas que estão
referenciadas
muitas delas são do topo em termos
internacionais empresas portuguesas que
estão no topo do da estrutura é
internacional de investigação e para tal
algumas delas controladas produtos um
arm test to harm provando assim é que os
produtos sejam testados por nós ou é com
provas dadas em 30%
esta foi o espectro que o burnley a
pouco está em 2007 fazendo a ponte com
aquilo que te dizem estar pouco é que
nós tivemos quando quando a cada gol é
questões dragão onde nós vamos lá também
nos conselhos unidades após e vimos o
que quer de emergência é das pessoas que
essa resistência o que essa segunda
missão que conseguem fazer do tema
e aí nós entramos também naquilo que são
em 2007 temos com todos estes módulos
que aqui estão
eliminados alguns deles são chile dados
única que possui na zona e inclusiva da
área das operações especiais é nec nos
os módulos de vigilância deteção de
vítimas e e salvamento é do grande golo
por exemplo em 2018 é estas foram essas
áreas em que estivemos atuar com o egito
com a seleção quando três das florestas
com os protocolos com os municípios e
com a autoridade nacional de proteção
civil
caros amigos agora passava para aquilo
que é o meu objeto de um objeto é a
emissões no exterior desde 1996 quando
começaram as transmissões de paz é já
devolvemos um total de mais de 25 mil e
militares
estou falando em forças nacionais
destacadas fossem sair de casa são
constituídas com o mando é e um conjunto
de alimentos inal da companhia muito
nessa missão
para além disso temos movimentos sociais
sindicatos que enviamos individualmente
é para cortez finais o ponto tipos de
missões é e para para vos dizer que que
é do filme estão em timor na bósnia no
com jogo em todos estes locais e o
popular de alunos que foram fritz aquino
no breve leitura do documento que que
fizeram se presente em opções na
história antiga é uma história é este
presente no afeganistão e os exemplos
que têm um desligamento frio estão é
plano e ensinar algo ao que julgo vant
que passei pelos meus filhos foi é
relativizar aquilo que é o nosso
pensamento sobre o que é pobreza o que é
o sofrimento
quando vim da missão do afeganistão
um outro bandido porque o que vi
fica na memória para sempre é e foi esse
pensamento que passei para a minha
família para além dos militares com quem
diariamente trabalho
pra ter uma noção do que é pobreza o
sofrimento é morta é todo o tempo
o perigo todo o tempo e se vive queda
como coitado acima de tudo pela
população civil
essa ausência de proteção é que tem é
algo que os militares que andam em
operações e trazem também consigo e que
em princípio devem passar aos seus
subordinados logo em termos militares
mas também aos seus familiares e amigos
dos seus mais próximos de casa de amigos
nesta altura é portugal está neste as
opções são 8 500 processos em que em que
estamos com mais força da mente daqueles
onde temos mais militares é é no flu
estão na resolução esporte mission onde
temos também militar de operações
especiais nesta altura é cumprir a
missão do módulo de segurança de uma
grande escola faz o time mas a maioria
das fria e é e onde temos dois tipos de
missões uma european union training
mission é que é comandada por um oficial
general português durante o ano de 2018
continuará para 2019 e príncipe estreou
o o próximo quando essa força e também
na missão do da música da missão motor
dimensional claro que nem a frente onde
temos a força que nessa altura traz a
primeira missão mais importante todas
importação e salvaguarda das pessoas na
república centro africana
a emissão que eu levo como mais
importante todos já sofremos aqui porque
como free é essa missão do pne
transmission tem como objetivo
providenciar o constrangimento de otegi
que esqueçam o treino
o ministro da defesa e forças armadas
centro africanas
e apoiar a modernização das forças
armadas de forma a tornarem
autossustentáveis credíveis os
responsáveis imediatamente porque
precisa ficar num país que é do tamanho
da frança e da bélgica junto em termos
função tem menos do portugal e é uma
democracia frágil a não ser para não
dizer que é um estado exíguo e nesse
papel que esta missão da união européia
ué é chefiada por portugal com cerca de
160 elementos está a trabalhar nesse
sentido levantar e fez novo também nos
apoiar nessa empresa
e finalmente a missão da minha música
que aquela que considero que é mais
relevante todas as missões que nós
estamos apenas no turno anterior
caros amigos é eu estive em agosto
primeiro eu estive em julho ea república
centro-africana acompanhar a comissão
parlamentar de defesa é um elemento da
comissão parlamentar de defesa que lá
foram e vieram online o cinismo pobreza
do país e com o trabalho que está a ser
feito outro lado o nós temos uma
componente importante
em agosto havia aqui é em portugal o
representante especial do secretário
geral das nações unidas o embaixador é
para fahel na vaga que nos transmitiu
tudo aquilo que é sua grande satisfação
e alegria o seu agradecimento pela
missão que portugal está a desempenhar
para ter uma noção é minha música é a
operação em si é comandada por um
tradicional e cingalês ao ataque e vamos
ver na próxima semana é tem um efetivo
da ordem dos 12 mil homens
só essa profissão desde 2001 cerca de
160 são portuguesas dentro sempre
conversando menos 1.160 que inclui uma
componente serviço inclui uma companhia
com uma componente de apoio aéreo e
incluir uma componente de combate
furadeira mesmo porque isso que eles
fazem lá não é
a manutenção paz é uma opção limpa seção
passo que a nossa força uma força de
intervenção rápida mankiewicz action
força eo jornal ballack tac o comandante
das forças e tem dois mil homens diz que
esta força que nós temos está em 160 mil
hectares são o seu cristiano ronaldo
basicamente quando entram para resolver
e entram e resolvem e entre 1 e entrou
em combate
poderia não são estes fazem e protegem
as funções evitam as mortes foi de
mortes provocadas pelos bandos armados
nos antigos placar e pelo sangue e pelo
sexo é k são é de origem muçulmana e
evitam que mais mortes possa haver e
conseguem proteger tempos dos refugiados
temporários de ordem de 20 mil pessoas
que rapidamente se agregam a volta
quando sabem que o contingente português
não está ou evitam situações de mais
mortes
quando é o slac estes muçulmanos
atacaram a igreja nossa senhora de
fátima
curiosidade pra vocês curiosidade pra
mim uma igreja nossa senhora de fátima
construir os trilhos em bangui na
capital da república centro africana
foram atacados por em cima às vezes com
muitas mortes inclusive o padre e os
soldados portugueses que irão lá para
defender
é isso que nós fazemos fora dignificar
portugal um grande portugal e dos
portugueses amigos
[Aplausos]